la parole est à monsieur jean louis
causse merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
l'éducation
madame la ministre l'objectif de votre
réforme du collège est soi-disant de
lutter contre l'ennui des élèves à
l'école voilà malheureusement
raisonnement qui ne va faire
qu'accentuer la déconstruction de
l'école de la république
depuis la loi de jospin de 1989
la gauche a placé les envies des élèves
au coeur du système
reléguant le savoir au second plan les
élèves ont désormais le choix de
s'intéresser ou non à ce qu'on leur
propose
et s'il ne s'y intéressent pas c'est
alors au corps enseignant de s'adapter
résultat on ne fait plus de dictée et on
simplifie la grande mère parce que la
langue française est trop complexe
on apprend plus les tables de
multiplication par terre parce que les
élèves ont des calculatrices
voilà comment le seul président madame
la ministre en quelques années on a
détruit une école qui faisait la fierté
de notre nation à travers le monde
alors le constat aujourd'hui est
édifiant la france ne cesse de reculer
au classement pisa visage crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord la maîtrise de la
langue française est désastreuse même
chez les étudiants de mon niveau et les
plus jeunes mais connaissent de plus en
plus les événements majeurs de notre
histoire
alors quand vous accusée no rang de
prôner l'élitisme à l'école permettez
moi de sourire
justement seul à plaider en est hélas
que notre école ne forment plus assez
d'élite et c'est bien à cause de vos
réformes successives
vous nous dites que le développement des
pratiques interdisciplinaire va
permettre aux élèves de mieux maîtriser
des savoirs mais dans ce cas pourquoi
cette volonté ne s'applique-t-elle pas
au programme
comment les professeurs de lettres
parviendront-ils enseigner voltaire
montesquieu rousseau
si leur collègue d'histoire se font
l'impasse sur le siècle des lumières
madame la ministre votre réforme des
collèges et vos nouveaux programmes vont
contribuer encore une fois d'un drop
l'est justement ce que nous ne voulons
pas nous ne voulons pas de votre réforme
et nous ne sommes pas les seuls preuve
en est la mobilisation qui aura lieu
jeudi
il est grand temps de repenser le savoir
au coeur de l'école cela constituera en
fait une vraie réforme
madame la ministre je vous demande une
nouvelle fois de retirer votre réforme
merci la parole est qu'à madame najat
vallaud belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député cost merci pour votre
question qui me donne l'occasion donc de
vous donner des nouvelles de la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme du collège et de
celles à venir des programmes donc comme
je vous l'avais indiqué ici à partir de
demain nous recevrons les organisations
syndicales pour travailler sur les
textes d'application de la réforme qui
permettront à cette dernière d'entrer en
vigueur dans les meilleures conditions
possibles notamment en accompagnant et
en formant les enseignants qui sont en
charge de la mettre en oeuvre
je mets je vais répondre plus
directement d'abord sur la question de
l'acquisition du français vous avez
raison monsieur coste je ne peux qu'être
d'accord avec vous ça fait partie de ces
fondamentaux que nous devons veiller à
faire acquérir aux enfants à tous les
enfants et on ne peut plus se permettre
en effet qu'un enfant sur cinq sortent
du collège sans maîtriser ses
fondamentaux
c'est la raison pour laquelle la réforme
du collège a été initié c'est d'ailleurs
la raison au delà du collège pour
laquelle dans nos dernières mesures
adoptées et je vais vous les rappeler
ici nous mettons des exigences très
fortes sur cette question premièrement
en pré scolarisant les enfants avant
l'âge de 3 ans parce qu'on sait que les
écarts de vocabulaire et de langage
malheureusement s'installe très tôt en
fonction des situations sociales
deuxièmement en ayant revu le programme
de maternelle pour faire en sorte que là
ce qu'on appelle la conscience
phonologique c'est à dire le pré
apprentissage de la lecture de
l'écriture s'installe très tôt chez les
enfants troisièmement en instaurant à
partir de la rentrée prochaine comme je
lé annoncé une évaluation systématique
du niveau de français à l'entrée en ce2
quatrièmement en faisant en sorte que
dans les programmes
au collège on est des exigences plus
fortes s'agissant des programmes de
français avec des programmes plus
lisible plus cohérent mieux évaluer un
dernier mot pour vous dire s'agissant de
la réforme des programmes que comme je
vous l'avais indiqué les professeurs
sont consultés en ce moment sur ce sujet
qu ils nous rendront leurs conclusions
le 12
un prochain et que ensuite je serai
amené à adopter de nouveaux programmes
qui n'ont qu'une vocation mieux réussi à
désarmer la parole